so back to back to september for a
second how
close
was it to being a guest
do you do how close do you think that it
actually could have been
i think a lot closer than
people realize we built it it was built
it was it was ready to go um the
challenge was for for those of us that
uh you know saw manchester salty uh in
bonnaroo salty
we knew 04 and knowing the amount of
rain that we had in o4 yeah exactly i
was knowing the amount of rain we had no
for and and understanding what that did
to the property and what that did to the
experience what that did
all over the place it was going to be
worse
i think he just hit a point point that i
totally forgot about explain what it did
to the property because i had to pay a
kid 50 dollars to pull me out of a mud
pit um and this is just a random kid
from the neighborhood yeah and i think
jeff you're gonna you're gonna say it
but i know we talked about it i talked
about it is people don't understand
they see a mud puddle and they think
it's just a mud puddle they don't
understand what 80 000 people walking
through that mud puddle
does to it over a day or two right but
but yeah
that's a great question what i mean what
were you thinking
um
the what we lovingly call the back 60
and seeing how we had changed some
things up operationally and even if we
wouldn't have changed up things
operationally that you know that that
honestly that didn't matter there was
there was so much rain i mean i don't
i'd have to go back and look at you know
tennessee records but i think during
that span i think that had to have been
like the wettest time frame
like on record period it was just an
immense amount of rain and what would
happen the ground was so soft you put
any weight and when i say anyway i'm
talking like a human foot you've just
now created a mess
and
the could we have gotten everybody in
m maybe but the amount of disruption mud
just everything one who would have
destroyed the grounds two
everyone would have been stuck and no
one would have been getting out of it
and it would have been
it would have been a safety issue and i
think that's the other talk about talk
about some bad headlines afterwards oh
it would have been i mean like i mean
heck we talked about everything i
referenced tomorrow world uh beforehand
we all know what happened there i think
it would actually don't think i know it
would have been worse than that and it
it's not at a fault it's mother nature
you know she she she won in that level
so
when when people think you know like you
asked me like how close we got
the
amount of brain power that went into
every possible thing from opening up
refund windows to shifting things around
do we you know not open a day and open
up a day later in order to like let the
sun come in
i would say every single plausible and
even non-plausible option was put on the
table some executed and done to give us
a shot because
no one no one no one on that team even
the people who were slogging it out like
actually getting you know just
dirty muddy gross
um wanted to
bring it down when you make a call like
when you make a call like that how many
people are in the room
batting ideas around
uh i mean you know you bring in the
brain trust you know it's a small group
but it's you know you you bring in the
people who specialize and and know
certain things because as you know it's
like a ripple effect everything is
affected so like how does this impact
food vendors can they get shipments or
you know can they get their shipments in
to get stuff done can we service
porta-potties can we
all those different operational pieces
um factor into it and so
you solve one problem but you have to
make sure you didn't just create three
more and so it's a small team but you
got the best in the business in terms of
trying to figure it out and and share
that collective knowledge of
what happens to the property when it
gets wet and then what is needed to be
serviced to make things
you know
take place did anybody in the brain
trust disagree
no okay totally unanimous billy knows i
i think we there were some that you know
wanted to try
and push it but
it it's it's a safety issue i mean it
comes down you just can't you can't you
can't do that anymore like i don't think
you can take those types of risks
anymore it's not worth it to do it from
a standpoint of of
destroying the brand and and what has
been built over 20 years so you know
could you ramrodded it in there maybe
but then
then you're potentially killing it for
the next 20 years and is that worth it
and again i go back to just safety and
experience and if everyone has a crap
experience like it's just
your way that it's just it's just not
not worth it i think that's where that
salty thing comes i mean that's a
you were there in 2004
brad and i were in fork and louisville
you know with when the
gust nato or whatever the hell came off
the river and you know i remember you
running down the
running towards the stage get everybody
out of here yep uh
i'll never i'll never forget sam smith
poor sam smith comes out he says hello
louisville and then three seconds later
good night louisville
run